There are probably 10,000 stars for
every grain of sand on earth in the
observable universe. We know that
there might be trillions of planets,
so where are all the aliens?
This is the family, Tara dogs.
If you want to know more about it,
watch part one here we look at possible
solutions to the family paradox,
so will we be destroyed or does
a glorious future awaits us?
Space travel is hard over possible.
It's an enormous challenge
to travel to other stars.
Massive amounts of material had to
be put into orbit and assembled.
A Journey of maybe thousands of years
needs to be survived by population big
enough to start from scratch and the
planet might not be as hospitable as it's
seen from afar.
It was already extremely hard to set up
a spaceship that could survive the trip.
An interstellar invasion might
be impossible to put off. Also,
consider timing.
The universe is a very old on honor.
There's been life for at
least at 3.6 billion years,
intelligent human life
for about 250,000 years,
but only for about a century.
Have we had the technology to
communicate over great distances.
There might have been grand alien empires
that stretched across thousands of
systems and existed for millions of years.
Let me, might just have missed them.
There might be grandiose ruins
rotting away on distant worlds.
99% of all species on earth have died out.
It's easy to argue that this
will be our feet sooner or later.
Intelligent knife may develop,
spread over a few systems and
die off over and over again,
but to galactic civilizations
might never meet.
So maybe it's a unifying experience
for life in the universe to look at the
stars and wonder where is everyone?
But there is no reason to assume that
aliens on my costs or that our logic
applies to them.
It might just be the town means of
communication are extremely primitive and
outdated. Imagine sitting in a
house with a Morse code transmitter.
You'd keep sending messages,
but liberty would answer and
you'd feel pretty lonely.
Maybe we're still undetectable for
intelligence species and will remain.
So until we learn to communicate
properly and even if we met aliens,
we might be too different to be able to
communicate with them in a meaningful
way. Imagine the smartest squirrel
you can, no matter how hard you try,
you won't be able to explain
our society to it. After all,
from the squirrels perspective,
a tree is all the day sophisticated
intelligence like itself needs to survive.
So she Linds,
cutting down whole forests is madness,
but we do destroy forests because we hate
squirrels. We just want the resources,
the squirrels wishes and the squirrels
survival are of no concern to us.
A type three civilizations in need of
resources may treat us in a similar way.
They might just evaporate our oceans
to make collecting whatever they need
easier. One of the adience might
think for a second oh tiny. At Apes,
they build really cute
concrete structures.
Oh well now they're debt
before activating warp speed.
But if there is a civilization out there
that wants to eliminate other species,
it's a far more likely that it will
be motivated by culture rather than by
economics and anyway,
it will be more effective to automate
the process by constructing the perfect
weapon, a self replicating space
probe made from nano machines.
They operate on a molecular
level incredibly fast and
deadly with the power to
attack and dismantle
anything in an instant.
You only need to give them
four instructions. One,
find a planet with life to disassemble
everything on this planet into its
component parts.
Three,
use the resources to build
new space probes for repeat.
A doomsday machine like this could
render a galaxy sterile in a few million
years,
but why would you fly in light years
to gather resources or commit genocide?
The speed of light is
actually not very fast.
If someone could travel
at the speed of light,
it would still take 100,000 years to
cross the Milky Way once and you'll
probably travel way slower.
There might be way more enjoyable
things than destroying civilizations and
building empires. An interesting
concept as the Matryoshka Brighton,
a mega structure surrounding a star,
a computer of such computing power that
an entire species could upload their
consciousness and exists in a simulated
universe potentially one could
experience and it Turnitin of pure
ecstasies without ever been bored or sad.
A perfect life.
If built around a red dwarf,
this computer could be powered
for up to 10 trillion years.
Who would want to conquer the galaxy or
make contact with other life forms if
this were an option or these solutions
to the family paradox have one problem.
We don't know where the
borders of technology are.
We could be close to the limit or nowhere
near it and super technology awaits US
granting US immortality,
transporting us to other galaxies,
elevating us to the level of gods.
One thing we do have to acknowledge
is that we really don't know anything.
She have spent more than 90% of their
existence as hunter gatherers 500 years
ago. We thought we were the center
of the universe 200 years ago.
We stopped using human neighbor as the
main source of energy. 30 years ago,
we had apocalyptic weapons pointed
at each other because of political
disagreements in the galactic timescale.
We are embryos. We've come far,
but still have a long way to go.
The mindset that we are ready are the
center of the universe is still strong in
humans, so it's easy to make arrogant
assumptions about life in the universe,
but in the end, there's only
one way to find out, right?
Hey everybody,
we finally have our own sub
reddit come by for surveys,
discussions about future videos.
I think cues and stuff like that.
This video was made possible
by your support on Patrion.
If you want us to make more videos and
maybe get your own bird avatar in return,
check it out.